Snoop Diggity Doo Dog as you know said
that he was going to give up
smoke and when this ad came he posted it
to Instagram he said hey I'm giving up
smoke please respect my privacy Snoop
and I said hold
up all the fellas who be saying he's
soft Snoop don't play he's going to rock
it until the wheels fall off I thought
that we might actually be preparing for
a new episode so if Snoop was going to
give up the sin spinach Maybe he'd move
on
to puffing something else for those who
are listening right now I am in fact
tapping the Mayflower box but it turns
out Snoop had another trick up his
sleeve here it is I have an announcement
I'm giving up
smoke I know what you thinking Snoop
smoke is kind of your whole thing but
I'm done with it done with the coffin
and my clothes smelling all sticky icky
I'm going
smokeless solo sto fix fire they took
out the
smoke
clever Snoop is there obviously High
toasting a
marshmallow it's clever I love even the
commentary of the ad where he just looks
at you and you it's so officiously lame
that it's actually cool and funny again
he goes clever I'm going smoke for this
fire pit that I have
outside that dirty dog he got us again
now maybe I should send him a box of
Mayflower anyway you know maybe it's
just an opportunity right now go to
ziprecruiter.com with Thanksgiving just
a few days away I wanted to show some
gratitude to some of the people on my
team to Mr Davies and Professor Jacob
for producing our show to Dany producer
Danny for editing the show to the great
famous Tessa for keeping me on top of
everything I have to do every day takes
a team of amazing people to make this
show successful just like it takes an
amazing team to make any business
successful if you're hiring you need to
find the best people for your team you
need s recruiter right now you can try
it for free at Z recruit.com NCW Z
recruiter uses smart technology to scan
thousands of resumés to find the most
qualified people for your job zip
recruiter lets the most qualified people
know that they are a great match and
encourages them to apply zip recruiter
is trusted by millions in fact over 3.8
million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for their hiring needs see for
yourself why so many business owners are
hiring based on zip recruiter four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day I would be very grateful
if you would go to this exclusive web
address to try ZipRecruiter for free
ziprecruiter.com
ziprecruiter.com KW zi recruiter the
smartest way to hire there's a note I
wanted to read someone wrote into
me yes two days ago a listener wrote in
and some when I talk about dogs you know
I'm not a huge I'm not I'm not it's not
that I'm a dog person it's not that I'm
a cat person I say I'm a people person
and I wrote in or rather I I mentioned
this story about how pets don't make
people happier there's a study I think
studies are mostly bogus but when they
back up my points I site them and the
study said actually you think pets are
going to make you happy they really
don't pet owners and non-pet owners are
about equally happy and I said this is
important because there's no substitute
for
Humanity you maybe you can't have a
child maybe you're infertile a lot of
people deal with that it's a very tough
thing to deal with maybe you're not
called to marriage maybe you're not
called to Parenthood but you should be
involved with people you can be called
to a kind of spiritual Parenthood like
being you're a godmother Godfather maybe
you're a priest or otherwise
religious but you need to be involved
with people dogs aren't going to cut it
now I got this letter says Michael I'm a
45-year old mom of dog that completely
agrees with your opinion regarding dog
moms not dog parents as the men rarely
use the moniker I fully fell for the lie
that as a woman I could have it all I
graduated college with a BS in nursing
and an officer's Commission in the US
Air Force thank you for your service I
had every intention of seeing the world
finding the perfect man and being able
to work full-time while raising my
children but thanks to chick-flicks and
the feminist worm in my ear I kept
looking for the next best thing and
missed what was right in front of me I
fled from a wonderful man who wanted to
marry me because I had come to believe I
could do better wrong I bounced from man
to man always wanting something more I
lost out on my one opportunity to have a
family and suffered the pain and loss of
having to abort an ectopic pregnancy due
to complications associated with
endometriosis even though it was a
non-viable pregnancy I griev the loss of
that little zygote every day as a result
of my struggles I became closed off and
unable to accept love from men I
remained single to this day although
I've come to understand my mistakes and
accept my culpability I know I am also a
casualty of the leftist feminist
ideology I pray every day for healing
and guidance from God for he is truly
the only one who can make me whole and
worthy of Love since I'm single and
alone I've chosen a dog as a companion
for now it was either that or cats and I
refused to be a cat lady I also deal
with pts for my military service and was
graced with the gift of my Aussie doodle
puppy two years ago while I love him
dearly and I'm so grateful to have a
watcher while I pee I do my very best to
avoid the dog mom stereotype I also urge
every woman I talk to to avoid my
mistakes and accept that having it all
is impossible It's a cruel joke played
by the left and perpetuated by Hollywood
and the media it's so important to keep
telling women that there is always a
sacrifice when we try to have at all and
the real question is what are we willing
to sacrifice I grew up with a working
mom and dad I can say with no hesitation
I would have preferred my mom was home
more any child that has a working mom is
losing out on a very important Bond and
it will shape them in unimaginable ways
and forever harm their life I'm
fortunate enough to still have my mom
and dad together and in my life but many
adult children don't it's the truth that
the only thing I want from my parents is
is their time and Company money is
important for survival but you are so
right when you say a childless life is
not worth the small increase in income
I'm living proof I would give up that 8%
and more to be able to go back and fix
the dumbest mistake of my life I've
tried to be a parental figure by
sponsoring a child through Compassion
International I write letters to her and
try to be a good influence but it is a
pale imitation of what I should have I
have a 16-year-old nephew who is a
budding artist and I try to nurture his
talent but he lives far away and it's
difficult to communicate with them I
take solace that my nephew is was
homeschooled by my sister-in-law and I
tell her she's a hero every chance I get
I'm so worried about the future of
younger generations and how poorly
they've been raised many of whom have
been raised by public school teachers
have warped and poisoned their minds
have become they've become confused
about everything and are ripe for the
plucking by leftist Propaganda and
activism I encourage you to share my
story and keep talking about the
importance of faith in God family
children and committed couples these are
the only things that will save us from
the abyss of leftist ideology and agenda
and then she goes on to thank me for the
show uh really good letter thank you for
your letter sorry for the difficulty you
have faced but I I think it was really
articulate and you you have you are
giving people the grace of teaching by
example of the things you've learned
really good lesson man what a great clip
that was now hey hey hey come on Jack
come on man ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael NS YouTube channel see you
next time